my name is Jim Abernathy I'm a shark
expedition leader
I'm the pioneer of large cageless shark
encounters worldwide my whole
conservation effort is based on the
simple fact that our wildlife on planet
Earth especially sharks are worth more
alive I knew that I wanted to focus on
the world's largest predatory sharks so
I searched all of the Bahamas looking
for this place and finally found Tiger
Beach there's such a diversity of
species the tiger shark the great
hammerhead the bull shark the lemon
shark the Caribbean reef shark
Pocahontas is just one of the great
hammerheads that lives at Bahamas this
time of year if we were to kill her her
fins would probably be worth around 350
or 400 dollars but Bahamas has embraced
shark diving it's literally about a
hundred and thirteen million dollars
annually every single year that this
shark and others like her are generating
year after year after year alive as a
renewable resource so clearly it doesn't
make sense they're worth more alive it
saddens me greatly to see that on every
single dive everywhere I go on the
planet you're seeing the effects of our
plastic pollution you're seeing the
effects of our water pollution we have
quite literally used our only home as a
garbage dump we are at a pivotal point
in the history of our planet we're about
to lose sharks and many other animals if
we don't step up to the plate right now
and make the changes that we need to do
in order to protect sharks worldwide we
need to take care of the animal that's
responsible for
painting to health and balance of our
oceans it's that simple
so whether you like sharks or hate
sharks for our own existence on the
planet as well as the future of planet
Earth we need to protect sharks
you